so i've written here three different
functions the first one is a
multivariable function it has a two
variable input x y
and a single variable output that's x
squared times y that's just a number and
then the other two functions are each
just regular old single variable
functions and what i want to do is start
thinking about the composition of them
so i'm going to take as the first
component the value of the function x of
t
so you pump t through that and then you
make that the first component of f and
the second component will be the value
of the function y of t
so the image that you might have in your
head for something like this is you can
think of t
as just living on a number line of some
kind
then you have x and y
which is just a plane so that'll be
you know your x coordinate your y
coordinate two dimensional space
and then you have your output which is
just whatever the value of f is and for
this whole function
for this whole composition of functions
you're thinking of x t y t as taking a
single point in t and kind of moving it
over to two dimensional space somewhere
and then from there our multivariable
function takes that back down so this is
just a single variable function
nothing
you know nothing too fancy going on in
terms of where you start and where you
end up it's just what's happening in the
middle
and what i want to know is what's the
derivative of this function
if i take this and it's just an ordinary
derivative not a partial derivative
because this is a single variable
function one variable input one variable
output how do you take its derivative
and there's a a special rule for this
it's called the chain rule the
multivariable chain rule but you don't
actually need it so let's actually walk
through this
showing that you don't need it it's not
that you'll never need it it's just for
computations like this you could go
without it
it's a very useful theoretical tool a
very useful model to have in mind for
what function function composition looks
like and
implies for derivatives in the
multivariable world
so let's just start plugging things in
here if i have f of x of t of y of t the
first thing i might do is write okay f
and instead of x of t just write in
cosine of t
since that's the function that i have
for x of t
and then y we replace that with sine of
t
sine of t
and of course i'm hoping to take the
derivative of this
and then from there we can go to the
definition of f f of x y equals x
squared times y which means we take that
first component squared so we'll take
that first component
cosine of t
and then square it
square that guy and then we'll multiply
it by the second component
sine of t
sine of t
and again we're just taking this
derivative
and you might be wondering okay why am i
doing this you're just showing me how to
take a first derivative an ordinary
derivative but the pattern that we'll
see is going to lead us to the
multivariable chain rule and it's
actually kind of surprising when you see
it in this context because it pops out
in a way that you might not expect
things to pop out
so continuing our chugging along when
you take the derivative of this you do
the product rule lefty right times plus
right d left so in this case the left is
cosine squared of t we just leave that
as it is
cosine squared of t
and multiply it by the derivative of the
right d right so that's going to be
cosine of t
cosine of t
and then we add to that right which is
you know keep that right side
unchanged multiplied by the derivative
of the left and for that we use the
chain rule the the single variable chain
rule where you think of taking the
derivative of the outside so you hope
that plop that 2 down like you're taking
the derivative of 2x but you're just
writing in cosine instead of x
cosine t
and then you multiply that by the
derivative
by the derivative of the inside that's a
tongue twister um
which is negative sine of t
negative sine of t and i'm afraid i'm
gonna run off the edge here
certainly with the many many parentheses
that i need uh i'll i'll go ahead and
rewrite this though i'm going to rewrite
it anyway because there's a certain
pattern that i
hope to make clear
so let me just rewrite this side
just copy that down here
i just want to rewrite this guy
you might be wondering why but it'll
become clear in just a moment why i want
to do this
so in this case
i'm going to write this as
2
times cosine of t
times sine of t
and then all of that multiplied by
negative sine of t
negative sine of t
so this is the derivative this is the
derivative of the composition of
functions that ultimately was a single
variable function but it kind of went
through two different variables
and i just want to make an observation
in terms of the partial derivatives of f
so
let me just make a copy of this guy
give ourselves a little bit of room down
here
just paste that over here
so let's look at the partial derivatives
of f for a second here
so if i took the partial derivative with
respect to x
partial partial x
which means y is treated as a constant
so i take the derivative of x squared to
get 2x
and then multiply it by that constant
which is just y
and if i also do it with respect to y
get all of them in there
so now y looks like a variable x looks
like a constant so x squared also looks
like a constant constant times a
variable the derivative is just that
constant
these two their pattern comes up in the
ultimate result that we got and this is
the whole reason that i rewrote it if
you look at this 2xy you can see that
over here where cosine corresponds to x
sine corresponds to y based on our
original functions
and then x squared here
corresponds with squaring the x that we
put in there
then if we take the derivative of our
two intermediary functions the ordinary
derivative of x with respect to t
that's derivative of cosine
negative sine
of t
and then similarly derivative of y just
the ordinary derivative no partials
going on here
with respect to t
that's equal to cosine derivative of
sine is cosine
and these guys show up right you see
negative sine over here
and you see cosine show up over here
and we could generalize this we could
write it down and say at least for this
specific example it looks like the
derivative of the composition is
this part which is the partial of f
with respect to y
right that's kind of what it looks like
here once we've plugged in the
intermediary functions
multiplied by this guy was the ordinary
derivative of y with respect to t
so that was the ordinary derivative of y
with respect to t
and then very similarly this guy was the
partial of f with respect to x
partial x and we're multiplying it by
the ordinary derivative of x of t so
over here x of t
with respect to t
and of course when i write this partial
f partial y what i really mean is you
plug in for x and y
the two coordinate functions x of t y of
t
so if i say partial left partial y over
here what i really mean is you take that
x squared and then you plug in x of t
squared to get cosine cosine squared and
same deal over here you're always
plugging things in so you ultimately
have a function of t
but this right here has a name this is
the multivariable chain rule uh and it's
important enough i'll just kind of i'll
just write it out all on its own here
if we take the ordinary derivative with
respect to t
of a composition of a multivariable
function in this case just two variables
x of t
y of t where we're plugging in two
intermediary functions x of t y of t
each of which just single variable the
result
is that we take the partial derivative
with respect to x
and we multiply it by
the derivative of x with respect to t
and then we add to that
the partial derivative with respect to y
multiplied by the derivative of y with
respect to t
so this entire expression here
is what you might call the simple
version of the multivariable chain rule
and you get there's a more general
version and we'll kind of build up to it
but this is the simplest example you can
think of where you you start with one
dimension and then you move over to two
dimensions somehow and then you move
from those two dimensions down to one
so this is this is that and in the next
video i'm going to talk about the
intuition for why this is true you know
here i just went through an example and
showed oh it just happens to be true it
fills this pattern but there's a very
nice line of reasoning for where this
comes about
and i'll also talk about a more
generalized form where you'll see it we
start using vector notation it makes
things look very clean
and i might even get around to a more
formal argument for why this is true
so see you next video